se conoció la histórico mundial tendrá
una consecuencia sobre la iglesia
católica mundial porque es algo que ya
es ineludible después para la iglesia
francesa desgraciadamente estoy un poco
dubitativo porque voy a criticar a
nuestros obispos pero siempre han
actuado obligados y forzados
lo que yo habría esperado es una
reacción con ímpetu es decir que
ofrecieran su renuncia colectiva como lo
hicieron los de chile
que la única solución es la del papá
francisco es decir afrontar e ir hacia
la reforma a principios de noviembre
iniciaron su asamblea plenaria de otoño
en lourdes y claramente hablarán del
tema pero se necesitan comités de
seguimiento de víctimas y de fieles para
seguir empujando los porque no creo que
lleguen ahí por sí mismos el boom
continua después de varios parques
yárritu serbio ahora o intervienen hacen
las reformas y toman las medidas e
indemnizan correctamente a las víctimas
o las cosas mal para ellos sus ojos